Зараз будемо запускати в акваторію Київського водосховища. Радіус до 15 км.
Будемо летіти в напрямку гирла річки Прип’ять.
Безпілотник "Spectator-М " вже три роки застосовують в Житомирському прикордонному загоні,
який охороняє 600 кілометрів кордону з Білоруссю в трьох областях: Київській,
Житомирській, Рівненській. Цього разу завдання безпілотника -
пролетіти над Київським водосховищем і Чорнобильською зоною, яку по периметру
теж охороняють прикордонники. Зона пролягає безпосередньо
на лінії українсько-білоруського кордону, тож усі переміщення людей
або техніки мають бути зафіксовані.
Коли ми летіли в самій зоні, біля дуги "Чорнобиль-2", то було виявлено п'ять осіб,
які незаконно потрапили в зону відчуження з метою екстремального туризму.
В зоні можемо побачити також вивезення забруднених матеріалів - металобрухту.
Ми спостерігаємо за ними, міняємо маршрут польоту і повідомляємо Нацполіцію.
Головні порушники кордону біля зони - сталкери, любителі позбирати почасти
радіоактивні гриби та ягоди. Всіх цих людей прикордонники повинні
перевіряти: кажуть, ризик, що це можуть бути диверсанти, доволі великий.
Мовляв, ця територія Полісся ще з часів Другої світової війни була
ідеальним плацдармом для діяльності розвідників та диверсійних груп.
Політичні події в республіці Білорусь в останні півтора року, дедалі більше
зближення офіційного Мінська з Москвою створюють на цій ділянці кордону
додаткові і доволі серйозні ризики.
З 2014 року Держприкордонслужба України переведена в посилений режим
несення служби уздовж усієї лінії кордону.
Як показав 2014-ий рік, з боку РФ також за великим рахунком ніхто не очікував,
що можуть бути якісь дії, але ми бачимо, до чого це призвело.
Тому кордон ми охороняємо посилено. На сьогодні ми не спостерігаємо руху будь-яких військових,
скупчення військових, груп військової техніки поблизу державного кордону.
Ми не спостерігаємо якогось на воді збільшення чисельності катерів
військового призначення. Охорону кордону республіка Білорусь здійснює повсякденно.
Ми здійснюємо посилено.
На Київському водосховищі, а також на річках Прип’ять і Дніпро щоденно
патрулюють катери морської охорони.
Кормовий на борту.
Як каже екіпаж, порівнювати українсько-білоруський кордон з тим,
що відбувається на українсько-російському кордоні, не варто. Та і  Київське море -
це не Азовське і не Чорне, де постійно відбуваються різні провокації, зокрема з боку росіян.
За час мого патрулювання не зустрічав військові угрупування.
Тільки прикордонні катери білоруські. Вони також патрулюють свою місцевість
по своїй ділянці - трохи вище по Дніпру.
Білоруські прикордонники, як каже командир, попри погіршення відносин
між Києвом та Мінськом тримають нейтралітет.
Ми до них не підходимо, вони до нас не підходять, не контактуємо з ними.
Вітатися можемо, але не всі патрулі ввічливі та чемні. Вони навіть
можуть не відреагувати на наші жести.
Мічман Василькевич служить в Житомирському загоні з 2009 року.
Каже, що керування морським катером на морі та на річках - цілковито різні речі.
Морська хвиля велика та довга. На Київському водосховищі хвилі короткі та часті.
По навігації, як на морі, тут не походиш. Річкові водні шляхи -
це постійна потенційна небезпека натрапити на дерево під водою, на мілини,
які з’являються там, де їх не було. Тож патрулювання потребує великої концентрації уваги.
Помічати треба все, що під водою, над водою, на воді і поблизу води -
в усіх цих кущах, заводях, де можна сховати будь-що.
Здійснювали повітряний моніторинг річки Прип’ять, виявляємо судна, спостерігаємо.
Човнами не завжди до них можна підійти. Деякі місця зверху набагато краще
видно і підійти можна. Дуже полегшує нам службу.
Порушники, з якими має справу екіпаж, це браконьєри, які проводять незаконний вилов риби,
судна чи човни, які не оформили дозвіл на перебування в прикордонній зоні
чи взагалі без документів. Випадків, коли хтось намагався прорватися через водний кордон
чи кордон України на суші зі зброєю не було, кажуть прикордонники.
Як не було зафіксовано і переміщення диверсійно-розвідувальних груп.
Єдине, що виявили минулого року, - один схрон з легкою зброєю біля
українського кордону на суші. Це стало ще одним аргументом
для заяв офіційного Мінська про те, що з України в Білорусь
нібито може потрапляти зброя. За оцінками експосла України в Білорусі Романа Безсмертного,
ситуація на кордоні з Білоруссю, особливо на Поліссі, лише офіційно
виглядає спокійною. Геополітично ця ділянка українського  кордону,
на його думку, є найменш захищеною.
Ця частина кордону україно-білоруського, яка формально звучить так,
вона з білоруської сторони знаходиться в управлінні Кремля.
Я зараз скажу метаморфічну річ: скоро на цій ділянці можна буде ногою
копнути мурашник, і там ви знайдете зброю або закладку якусь.
Те, що українська сторона, спецслужби, прикордонники, кажуть, що все гаразд,
то вони - молодці. Вони мають казати, що все гаразд. Але українські спецслужби
дуже добре поінформовані, що відбувається з білоруського боку.
Більше того, навіть Мінськ не все знає, що Росія робить на тисячах кілометрів кордону
між формально Білоруссю і Україною. Це не предмет діяльності Лукашенка.
Це предмет діяльності ФСБ РФ. Це ділянка, яка завжди використовувалася
для діяльності розвідувально-диверсійних груп, контрабандистських груп.
Біля кордону - важливий стратегічний об’єкт - ЧАЕС зі сховищами
відпрацьованого ядерного палива. Навколо зона, де майже немає жителів,
а дороги стають дедалі гіршими. Попри наявність усіх сучасних технічних засобів,
сил прикордонників, СБУ, Нацгвардії, ЗСУ, які там присутні, проконтролювати зону важко.
Цей наряд прикордонників щодня патрулює периметр зони.
Звертаємо увагу на нові дірки, які з'являються в паркані тилової межі.
На думку експосла в Білорусі Безсмертного, особливості території Чорнобильської зони
перетворюють її на потенційний плацдарм для військових дій.
За даними українського дипломата, навпроти України в Білорусі
після усіх військових навчань за три роки нібито накопичено
доволі багато і військових, і техніки РФ.
Це десь приблизно 15 000, не враховуючи дві військові бази і третя, що будується.
Російських військових на території Білорусі набагато менше, вважає експерт
з міжнародної політики, білорус за національністю Ігар Тишкевич.
Його прогнози щодо імовірної агресії з боку Білорусі більш стримані.
Подивіться на озброєння білоруських прикордонників, з точки зору катерів
та інших плавзасобів. Це близько 10 катерів, які не є бойовими,
які є патрульними. Чим? На плотах з прапорами?
Якщо ми говоримо про накопичення військ, то станом на сьогодні є два військові об’єкти
на територіїї Білорусі. На початок 2021 року було 890 російських військових,
з яких рота охорони зі стрілецькою зброєю - біля 96 осіб.
І друга частина - вузол зв’язку ВМС, з 250-ти персоналу російського було 140.
Це здебільшого офіцери ВМС, які озброєні лише пістолетами. Ось і все накопичування.
З точки зору військової загрози, так, я розумію логіку України,
що будь-які навіть потенційні фактори загрози треба враховувати, треба реагувати.
Експерт  вважає найнебезпечнішим напрямком потенційної агресії
кордон не з боку Київщини, чи Житомирщини, а з боку Чернігівської області.
Експосол в Білорусі Безсмертний застерігає, що в гібридній війні можуть бути задіяні різні сценарії.
У Кремля в цій ситуації дуже великий інструментарій для нанесення удару по Україні.
І не випадково роками від рупорів Кремля ми чули…
Наприклад, Жириновський… Мовляв, перекриємо воду у Дніпрі, та і все. Чули? Чули.
Або - реалізуємо радянську модель відомого водоканалу між Дніпром
і фактично повернемо русло. Ці проєкти не просто проговорювалися,
а в радянські часи розроблялися.
Україні слід приділяти увагу і біобезпеці Дніпра, з якого п’є воду більшість населення України,
і ретельно контролювати рух транспорту по Дніпру.
Лінія кордону по річці проходить так, що білоруси мають потрапляти
з одного свого регіону до іншого через територію України.
Звідси до кордону з Білоруссю приблизно 60 кілометрів. Ось тут починається річка Прип’ять
і до Чорнобильської катастрофи сюди ходили судна до портів "Чорнобиль"
та "Прип’ять". Наразі прохід тут заборонений, окрім білоруських суден,
які, відповідно до міжнародних угод, можуть прямувати до київського порту
або до білоруських портів на Дніпрі.
Ось так виглядає прохід білоруських суден територією України.
Українські прикордонники супроводжують судна під час всього маршруту,
ретельно стежачи за усіма їхніми діями, хоча  вантажі, які перевозять білоруси
через Прип’ять, частину Київського моря і Дніпро, здебільшого промислові.
В актуальній політичній ситуації це робиться, в тому числі, і для запобігання
проникнення диверсійних груп.
Виходячи з місцевості, загрози є, тому що кораблі - вони великі, заховати можна будь-що.
Ми їх супроводжуємо до річкового порту і прикриття здійснюємо таким чином,
що судно до берега не має права приставати. І будь-який плавзасіб до нього підійти не може.
Завдання прикордонників на цій водній ділянці кордону - забезпечення постійної присутності.
Нам додали більше патрулів. Раніше ми два-три рази патрулювали ділянку.
То зараз від 5 до 8 разів на день. Вранці вийшли і можемо патрулювати до ночі.
На українсько-білоруському кордоні побільшало і ось таких мобільних контрольних пунктів,
які встановлюють періодично на різних ділянках кордону.
Сусідній берег - це вже республіка Білорусь.
Знімальна група DW провела на прикордонному катері понад 5 годин.
За весь цей час прикордонники не зустріли жодного порушника.
Ось тільки знайшли сітку, яка була встановлена на межі зони, де не можна ловити рибу.
Доказів того, що до цього можуть бути причетні катери поблизу,
у прикордонників не було. Тож після перевірки, чи не заплуталася сітка в двигуні,
її відкидають на безпечну від дозволеного маршруту пересування відстань,
аби в неї не заплуталися маленькі човни.
Чисто.
"Чисто" у військових означає "територія вільна від противника".
Прикордонники сподіваються, що чисто буде і далі.
Попри наявність сучасніших засобів контролю, чи не головними
своїми помічниками вони вважають місцевих жителів.
Усі ці рибалки, селяни та навіть ось ці відпочивальники на березі Київського моря
бачать інколи набагато більше.
Спецслужби України цього року не без допомоги місцевих затримали
в прикордонних областях двох агентів ФСБ Росії та КДБ Білорусі.
Цього року нарешті завершена демаркація українсько-білоруського кордону.
Це означає, що прикордонники обох держав мають чітко визначену лінію кордону
і, відповідно, жоден грибник чи ягідник тепер не зможе сказати, що не знав,
де проходить кордон. З обох боків - на суші та на воді тепер встановлені чіткі,
хоч поки і тимчасові, знаки лінії кордону. Як швидко український кордон
буде облаштований і коли всі необхідні інженерні комунікації з’являться
на всіх пунктах пропуску, тепер залежить від Верховної Ради,
яка має ухвалити деякі зміни до законодавства та затвердити фінансування.